brie
kids think i'm mama oh gosh you guys
don't even know our kids keeps getting
confused marie's kids get so confused
with her and i bet he goes mama and i go
no it's dodo no
no mama you're not dodo and i'm like no
i i'm dodo nikki and brie bella's kids
have to do a double take when it comes
to figuring out who their mama is her
and i just started to realize that here
we're in it together now we're both moms
every day you have your baby gear and i
told her i'm like you just see your life
is going to change during a new episode
of the bellas podcast the former wwe
pros and identical twins revealed that
bree's kids often confuse her with nikki
especially bree's one-year-old son buddy
i'm about to walk back to go back to
mateo and buddy goes mama and i go no
it's dodo no
no mama you're not dodo and i'm like no
i i'm dodo no mama and he wouldn't like
letting it shot yeah and brie says
seeing buddy after nap time doesn't make
anything easier and yesterday he wakes
up from a nap
i walk in there and he he literally does
this big back bump and he goes no dodo
no and i'm like no it's mama
no dodo no
i heard him screaming in the other room
and i'm like
screaming no dodo yeah oh my gosh she
said i mean nightmare about me i had to
like squat down and like look through
the crib handlebars
and i was like bud it's mama and then
finally he stopped crying and he goes
mama and i'm like don't i have a certain
scent now let's be fair it's easy to get
those two mixed up so buddy don't worry
totally understandable yeah it's crazy
it's been a trip to see it all it is and
i kind of look at you and i i'm looking
right now do we look that much alike i
mean we're twins but despite the kids
confusion there's no doubt the twin
sisters are loving motherhood along with
buddy brie has five-year-old daughter
birdie with her husband brian danielson
while nikki shares 23 month old son
mateo with fiance artem chigvinsiv last
year when e.t caught up with the duo
they couldn't help but gush about
raising their babies when matteo says
like mom or mama and and the love he
gives me i'm like this is living this is
life it's been so
incredible like i just and you become so
selfless like it is really crazy
everything that i used to be so worried
about like that doesn't even matter
anymore like he does i wake up and i
think of him and i go to bed and i think
of him and
like life has changed so much for me
it's true though and when it comes to
their little ones following in their
mama's wrestling career path well brie
says she's all for it while nikki thinks
mateo might be following in his dad's
dancing footsteps whatever they want to
do i'm going to support so if they want
to be wrestlers i'll support that and i
do there's a part of me
and i know if it's because like as a
woman to see like my daughter like kind
of follow my footsteps kind of makes me
like gives me goosebumps i think my
guess is matteo is gonna be
a dancer and a soccer player because he
has fast feet he moves his feet a lot
points his toes perfectly yeah
[Music]
you